SETH LADD: Welcome, everyone.
This is Dartisans, Episode 5.
Today's topic--
the Dart Virtual Machine, with
special guests from the Dart
Virtual Machine.
We have engineers who work on
the project with us today to
talk about the project, answer
your questions, and give us an
idea of what's been going on
with the VM, what they're
working on now, and perhaps even
what they see coming down
the pipe for the VM.
This is the Dart Hangout, and
we encourage everyone to
participate.
You can join us at
html5rocks.com/live to watch
this live feed.
Also, there's a chat
embedded there.
Also, links to the Moderator.
We will be taking your
questions later on.
So please do vote up and down
the questions there and submit
your own, of course.
And hopefully, you
can join us.
So add a comment
to the original
post for this broadcast.
And we'll try to add you to our
circles and invite you to
the Hangout.
This is for everyone
to participate.
So we hope you do provide
your questions and
jump in and join us.
Before we introduce the Dart VM
team here, who's joined us,
just a couple news in the Dart
community that I found pretty
interesting and cool over the
past couple of weeks I thought
I'd share with everyone.
This is a real big thanks
to Dartwatch.
They're on Google+.
And Chris Buckett, who runs that
page, has been doing a
great job collecting
all of the news.
So let me just run through some
of the cool things that
have been going on.
A couple weekends ago, there
were five different Dart
Hackathons across the globe.
London, Indonesia, Tokyo,
Kiev, and [INAUDIBLE]
Ukraine and saw some really cool
demos, feedback, projects
come out of these Hackathons.
We'll be posting a summary of
what everyone's been working
on and pointing out some of
the winning teams soon on
news.dartlang.org.
So do follow along there.
May 24th is an Introduction to
Dart in Munich, Germany.
I think that's a collaboration
with a couple different GTUGs
and JUGs and different user
groups and meet-ups there.
Some Dart engineers
will be on hand.
So that's May 24th in Munich.
Please do join them.
Alexander Orlov is organizing
a Dart Hackathon in Munich,
much in the style of the global
Hackathons that have
been happening all over.
Alexander's an early adopter in
the Dart project, and he's
looking for people to come by.
So we'll post all of these links
in the show notes, but
hopefully, you can join him in
Munich for the Hackathon.
Some cool projects that
I found recently.
John Evans, another one of our
early adopters in the Dart
community, wrote a great blog
post about how he contributed
to the Dart project.
Dart is open source.
You can find it at
dart.googlecode.com.
And he actually got his patch
in and worked with the
engineers to get it all
reviewed, and then talked
about his experience.
And so if you're interested
about how he did that and how
you might be able to contribute,
go ahead
and read his post.
John also works on Dart code.
And he ported a Z-Machine to
Dart, and you can find that on
GitHub, which is very,
very cool.
A couple other cool projects.
The GitHub user, Mythz--
M-Y-T-H-Z--
wrote a Redis driver.
Redis is a NoSQL key-value
store database that he's
written the Dart drivers for, so
that he can plug Redis into
his Dart applications via the
Dart Virtual Machine.
And the Google I/O sessions
were announced.
Most of them are now live.
And we have three sessions this
year at Google I/O, two
sessions in the main tracks, one
behind Dart with Lars Bak
and Kasper Lund.
And we also have, "Putting the
App Back into Web Apps," which
is talking about how Dart and
web programming intersect.
There's also a hands-on code
lab for Dart as well, where
you can get dirty with Dart
code, and you'll learn how to
write a client and server
app in Dart.
And so hope to see you at Google
I/O. And if you can't
be there, that's OK.
Everything is being recorded,
and a lot of stuff's being
live-streamed, so there's lots
of cool ways to participate.
And again, we'll post all of
these links in the show notes
as well later after
the broadcast.
So with that, we're going to
welcome our special guests,
some of our Dart Virtual
Machine engineers.
And we'll talk all about what's
going on in VM land.
So welcome, guys.
Thanks for coming
onto the show.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SETH LADD: So let's go around
the room really quickly, so
everyone gets an idea of--
I'm really interested in who
you are, but also what have
you worked on previously?
How did you become part
of this VM team?
And we'll start here
with Todd.
TODD TURNIDGE: I'm Todd
Turnidge, and I've
been on the team for--
I don't know.
Is it a year now?
Something?
IVAN POSVA: Somewhere like
nine months, or so.
TODD TURNIDGE: I used to do
virtual machines back in the
distant past, and I took a
break from it for awhile.
But it's nice to be back,
working again with some people
I've worked with before.
SIVA ANNAMALAI: Hi.
Yeah, my name is
Siva Annamalai.
I've been here for close to--
ever since the project started,
so it's been close to
two years now, I think.
And prior to this, I was also
working on virtual machines
with different languages and
different companies also.
And that's how I
got into this.
IVAN POSVA: Yeah.
I'm Ivan Posva.
Again, as Siva, I was
here from the
start of the Dart project.
Before that, I worked on V8, and
then at other companies.
I think I've worked with
everybody here in the room
outside of Google already.
So, yeah,
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE].
MALE SPEAKER 1: My name is
[? Surgeon Mentrovich. ?]
I've worked with Ivan
here already
before in other companies.
And we worked a little bit on
V8, a little bit matter taken
through Google.
And I have joined that project
from the beginning.
I'm having a lot of fun.
SETH LADD: Awesome.
Thanks, guys.
So building a virtual machine
seems like black magic.
This is always something that's
below the covers, under
the hood, if you will.
So for everyone watching, can
you help us just understand
what a virtual machine is?
Most people are familiar
with compilers.
They generate machine code, and
then you run that program.
But what's different in a
virtual machine world?
IVAN POSVA: So, I would say,
first of all, we want to keep
it black magic, so we won't
answer the question.
SETH LADD: OK.
IVAN POSVA: No.
OK, so how did we start?
Well, we have kind of an idea of
what the Dart language was
supposed to do.
So, Siva and I started in one
area where we just said, OK,
these aren't the VM objects
that we need.
This is the object hierarchy.
The VM's internal data
structures are also basically
in the VM heap.
They're garbage-collected, so
even though they're used from
C++, we keep them there.
And Siva started then
with handles and--
SIVA ANNAMALAI: Right.
So essentially, we had the
representation of all these
Dart objects in the VM.
But then we have to be careful
on how we access them, be
garbage collection aware, and
also we used this notion of
handles so that the code in the
VM itself is safe as far
as people writing it and
other aspects of it.
So that's a pretty big aspect
of the VM, is infrastructure
support for the garbage
collector.
And then, of course, there's
the open compilation, which
[? Surgeon ?] can talk about.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Yeah, the key
that appears as black magic is
we need a lot of discipline
when we design the system,
because the ability and
simplicity is of the utmost
importance.
And the same is of the compiler
part, which I was
working on, is to get the system
with gradually improved
performance, which we are now
on our way to do, but still
contain the ultimate
reliability, so that we cannot
allow the users to have crashes
when running our system.
So we have to be disciplined
and hard-working.
And I think, then, that black
magic-- it's not black magic,
white magic.
SETH LADD: Good.
Yeah, magic for good.
But I hear the terms "engine"
and "interpreter" and
"compiler" and "virtual
machine" So
I'm familiar with--
for instance, Ruby's an
implementation that really is
more of an interpreter, if
I understand correctly.
What's the difference between
that and a virtual machine?
IVAN POSVA: I wouldn't
say there's a
big difference, right?
So all of these language
virtual machines, they
implement one particular
language.
They either use an interpreter,
or in our case,
we skip the interpreter
step and go straight
to generated code.
SETH LADD: OK.
IVAN POSVA: Yeah, I think,
coming back to the black
magic, both Siva and
[? Surgeon ?] touched on it.
It's really, as I'm trying to
keep the overview of the whole
VM, trying to keep simple APIs,
keeping the VM hackable,
so that as you see changes need
to be made, the APIs,
between the different subsystems
are kept simple.
And that way, you can still--
nothing is set in stone,
essentially.
SETH LADD: Yeah, especially
this early in the project,
it's still a technology
preview.
We're learning a lot of good
lessons that we implement,
other people implement.
So that's good.
We have to have our meet
in the middle.
IVAN POSVA: And that
basically--
a lot of talk to change big
areas of the isolate
dispatching and so on.
SETH LADD: Yeah.
And we'll definitely come
back to isolates.
What about the life cycle
of Dart code then?
So you mentioned that we skip
the interpreter part, we go
straight to machine code.
At a high level, can you
just walk me through--
there's a compiler there.
What happens when we
take the Dart code?
SIVA ANNAMALAI: So essentially,
on the command
line, you specify a script that
is the Dart code that you
want to run.
So essentially, the VM, when it
starts up, it already does
a boot kind of thing where
it loads in all the code
libraries, which are
out there, actually
built into the VM.
Then we load the script.
We pass the script, tokenize
it, everything.
But we don't yet start
compiling the
methods at this point.
We just tokenize the screen.
And then there is the main
method that we invoke.
And that's when the
first compilation
happens of that method.
In the process, we are, of
course, creating objects in
the heap as we go along
with the script
object and other things.
And then, once the main
is compiled, we
start executing that--
machine code, that is--
which is compiled.
And that, in turn, we call other
methods, which trigger a
compilation of these other
methods and creation of each.
IVAN POSVA: So it's like
pulling on a string.
Once we tokenize the whole
thing, we have all the VM
internal data structures that
describe all the classes that
are part of this Dart program.
All of the methods, we sort of
know where the methods start.
So when main calls some other
method, we can pull on that.
We have the pre-chewed,
tokenized content of the
script for that part
of the method.
So we can basically,
lazily, as you go,
compile the little pieces.
And that works, actually,
pretty well.
TODD TURNIDGE: Yeah.
The optimizing compiler
kicks in later.
MALE SPEAKER 1: So essentially,
we have that code.
It's tokenized, and can use
it with the presentation.
And it has a two-stage
compilation system, which
first one collects all the
necessary information about
rampant behavior of
the language--
of the program.
And then from that one, we
decide to optimize and to use
all the latest and known and
still unknown optimization
technologies to get the best
performance out of the Dart.
TODD TURNIDGE: Currently,
we optimize
based on just a counter.
But it might change
in the future.
MALE SPEAKER 1: But this
is a flexible thing.
Right now we do simple so we can
develop the prototype as
soon as possible.
IVAN POSVA: And then the
optimization steps currently
are relatively simplistic, but
they allow again, as we try to
grow and so on.
So we get the type of feedback
from the running program.
We know, OK, generally--
or we've only see you called
this dynamic method here.
It always resolves to
that other class.
So we use that.
We use that knowledge.
SETH LADD: Now, you mentioned
performance.
And I believe some of the people
working on the Dart VM
used to work on V8.
Is that--
IVAN POSVA: That's correct.
SETH LADD: OK.
So what are some of the things
we learned as we built V8 that
prepped us for this next
generation virtual machine?
Maybe in terms of performance?
I know there's some things
that we now know to do.
MALE SPEAKER 1: I don't
think we have any--
we need just time to implement
all the features that we need.
There is sometimes a
new program from
JavaScript to Dart.
And you don't think of that as
a different language that may
pre-empt you if your program
acts in a way like it does
JavaScript.
But if our program does like
it's intended to be, you are
going to see performance
that Dart--
that is much better than a
JavaScript system can provide.
IVAN POSVA: So the lessons we
took from V8 was Crankshaft,
for example, showed that
having a really basic,
two-stage compiler, that the
second stage really kicked in
and used all the type feedback,
and started doing
advanced compiler optimizations
really pays off.
So that is what [? Surgeon's ?]
doing, applying some
of those lessons.
Other than-- yeah, go ahead.
SIVA ANNAMALAI: The thing that
Todd talked about of counting
and this thing, it was proven
that that works very well in
the Crankshaft scenario, too,
as opposed to seeing some
crazy, you know, taking
profiles, discounting scheme.
They've adopted it too,
now, I guess.
IVAN POSVA: Initially, they
used time-based profiling.
And they switched to
counters as well.
TODD TURNIDGE: And they talked
about object layout, some
things like that.
Is that a performance
lesson from V8?
IVAN POSVA: That is a
performance lesson from V8.
For example, what we
did in V8 was--
initially, we had just basically
the object with the
property values hanging
off to the side.
At some point, we had-- the
object had some room for
properties in the object itself,
so that it didn't have
to go through a double
D reference
to get at the object.
That was something that really
helped V8's performance.
And we said, V8, we have all
these heuristics to figure out
how big this area is.
Dart, as a language, is much
cleaner and safer that way.
You can't add new properties.
So you know exactly how much
you need to allocate.
SETH LADD: This is a really
interesting point that I
always find fascinating to watch
the team's work with, is
the intersection between
language design impacting VM
design and VM design impacting
language design.
It sounds like this is one of
those areas where we knew from
our prior experience that if you
have a language where you
can just add properties and
methods at run time, then you
can't necessarily take advantage
of some of the
deeper optimizations that we
then in the Dart language,
say, OK, well, if you can't
add a property, then that
means, well, we can be a little
bit more smarter in our
virtual machine.
IVAN POSVA: Or less smart.
Keep it more-- keep
it simpler.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SETH LADD: Keep it
simpler, yeah.
TODD TURNIDGE: Keep
it simpler.
Having fewer checks to
execute at run time.
SETH LADD: Can you talk more
about the dynamic between the
language design and
the VM design?
Do you work closely with the
guys building language?
Do you think it's really
just one big team?
How does that work?
IVAN POSVA: Todd, how loud do
you have to shout until you
reach loud?
TODD TURNIDGE: The language
specification fellow actually
sits at the desk beside mine,
so we have pretty much a
direct channel to him.
SETH LADD: That's awesome.
TODD TURNIDGE: And he works a
lot with the fellows over in
our groups who have primary
responsibility for language.
But most of those people, in
previous lives, were virtual
machine engineers.
So there's not really a wall in
terms of the knowledge of
virtual machine design.
Generally, they try not to give
us things that are too
hard to implement or that we
can't implement efficiently.
IVAN POSVA: Well, I don't think
they even thought about
doing stuff at Dart
to implement.
TODD TURNIDGE: Right.
It just wouldn't have--
They know Occult.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Even if we are
in different time zones, I
think, the communication between
[INAUDIBLE] and us
work pretty well.
And we give them feedback when
we find something that doesn't
seem to be working well from the
implementation standpoint.
Because in a design, having
thought of something, you
don't really know how well it
works until you have put it
down in the bits and bytes.
And that works well.
IVAN POSVA: I think it helps
that Kasper is also basically
working on dart2js.
So they feel some of
that same pain.
SETH LADD: So this always comes
up, especially when we
initially launched Dart, was,
oh, that's great, you have a
new language.
But why not work on a bytecode
VM and then let people kind of
tack on top of that?
Do you have any perspective on
the design of Dart as it is
today, where you have Dart code
that runs just pretty
much straight into the
virtual machine?
And what were some of the
design decisions there?
Why not a bytecode VM?
IVAN POSVA: Should I?
SIVA ANNAMALAI: Yeah,
go ahead.
No, go ahead.
IVAN POSVA: Well, to me,
I look at it this way.
When you have a bytecode
VM for Dart similar to
JavaScript, we always
want it to be
distributed as source code.
No precompilation steps
necessary for the developers.
So you really want to be able
to hit just reload.
You change your script,
reload, run.
No compilation script to
bytecode is necessary.
The option we could have had
was that the VM itself that
compiles bytecodes executes
those bytecodes in an
interpreter, and then basically
does the optimizing
compiler based on that.
We've opted skipping that step
instead of having a relatively
simple, fast compiler
to machine code.
And I sort of look at the CPU
as a really fast interpreter
of these x86 bytecodes.
MALE SPEAKER 1: I
don't see any--
I used to go to bytecodes, and I
don't see the clear benefits
for us using bytecodes.
It's an additional definition
that we need to maintain.
And the main reason I--
main argument for bytecodes, I
heard it from other people who
like to work with other
languages to run on our VM.
And for that, I think that that
is not a bad idea to use
as intermediate languages
by itself.
So if you have a language, you
can translate it to Dart and
run it from that point.
TODD TURNIDGE: Right.
And that can amplify--
every additional layer you
introduce is one more chance
for your definitions to have
a slight mismatch.
And so you have--
a method call is supposed to
behave this way at the
language level.
But at the virtual machine
level, maybe it acts slightly
differently.
It's more areas where you can
forget what's going on.
And if we always know this is
what the user typed in, then
we can do what the user said to
do at every point in time.
There's no middleman.
MALE SPEAKER 1: It clears
complexity.
And clear complexity means both
slower and less reliable.
SIVA ANNAMALAI: Yeah.
Actually, the bytecodes don't
actually skip the whole
passing phase, because we
still have to do the
verification of the bytecode
that comes in.
And so it's not like you're
saving on the
whole parsing thing.
So you still have
to do it anyway.
And having it in source form
doesn't make it any worse.
And like [? Surgeon ?] said,
interoperability is achieved
easily, because we already have
so many translators to
Dart language.
And you can just run it straight
as though it is an
intermediate representation.
SETH LADD: Good point.
It's very web-friendly
this way.
You hit it best where you--
reload is the new compile.
SIVA ANNAMALAI: Exactly.
SETH LADD: So you
need something
that works like that.
Yeah, great.
Thanks.
Switching gears a little bit, to
me, one of the great novel
features of the Dart virtual
machine is isolates.
Now, you've been working a
lot on isolates, Todd.
Can you explain, what
is an isolate?
Is it a thread?
Is it a process?
What does it do?
TODD TURNIDGE: Well, an isolate
is a lot like a
thread, but nobody else shares
any of its state.
So when you're writing an
isolate, you know that there's
no way that you have to have
locking or race conditions or
anything like that.
There's just perfect safety.
And all of your communication
with other isolates is done
with a message system.
And so it's a nice abstraction
for having parallel work but
without having a lot of the
things that really require a
lot of heavy thinking that you
have in other languages.
Here you have your isolate,
and there's a very strong
invariant about its
protection.
It's a lot more like a
process or something.
SETH LADD: I've heard parallels
drawn between our
isolate system and Erlang
actors, for instance.
Do you think that's
a fair analogy?
IVAN POSVA: That was definitely
part of it.
SIVA ANNAMALAI: That definitely
was part of the
inspiration, yeah.
The big thing being that, as
Todd mentioned, the heaps are
isolated, and there is
no sharing going on.
So it makes it--
as though you are just writing
a single-threaded program.
There's none of this whole
synchronization complexities
that people need to deal with.
And then when you interact with
other isolates, you just
message them.
TODD TURNIDGE: It even applies
in some of the internal VM
implementation, the fact that
we know that this isolate's
code can't really interact with
this other one's code.
And it means that we
could generate
simpler code for them.
We don't need to have a lot of
locking that goes on there.
I mean, we have a few data
structures in the VM that have
to do with how messages are
passed back and forth, or
about how threads are pulled
from a thread pool, the need
to be synchronization aware.
But most of the VM actually
gets to be
blissfully free of that.
IVAN POSVA: Essentially, only
the isolate implementation
ridge locks, and everything
else is, you know
you're the only guy.
SETH LADD: So it's pleasing.
And I think part of the isolate
is done to get the
census because Dart code has
to compile the JavaScript.
And JavaScript is itself
single-threaded, and so I can
see this interplay
of requirements.
But again, I think we end up
with a really nice system.
How are isolates implemented
today?
Is there a thread pool of one
process per isolate in the VM?
TODD TURNIDGE: Yeah.
About a month or so ago,
we switched from--
we used to be a thread per
isolate, which obviously
doesn't scale well.
When you're building a virtual
machine, often you'll say, I
want to get something
working now.
And then I'm going to make
it better and better.
And so we have this sort of
iterative, incremental
improvement.
And one of the things we
improved recently was we added
a thread pool.
So if a certain isolate is gone
to sleep, it's waiting
for message, and it'll be woken
up when it gets the
message sent to it.
Its thread goes into the pool.
And then the next isolate comes
along, and if it needs
to run, it can share it.
So it allows us to scale
more isolates
on top of your threads.
IVAN POSVA: There's still
more to be done.
TODD TURNIDGE: Yeah,
absolutely.
It's an area that we've just
scratched the surface on.
IVAN POSVA: So for example,
currently, we have the initial
heaps for per isolate are much
bigger than we would want to.
So we want to basically
grow them as needed.
We have still a lot of the core
library that is loaded.
Is it per isolate?
It's currently loaded
per isolate.
SETH LADD: Wow.
SIVA ANNAMALAI: There's a lot
of recent data on that that
comes in as part of the boot
process that is not modified
and can be shared
across isolates.
But that's something we
are looking at to
see how much of it--
again, this goes to Todd's
question of reducing the
footprint of an isolate, like
how the thread pool did it.
IVAN POSVA: And just basically
starting to squeeze on it.
SETH LADD: And so do you think
that when further iterations
of the isolate subsystem appear,
is the expectation
that developers can
start up a large
amount of these isolates?
Are they intended to
be lightweight--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SETH LADD: --constructs?
Great.
For sure.
IVAN POSVA: And again, as Todd
said, currently an isolate
becomes runnable, it
gets a thread.
And we might basically want
to limit how many
threads we want to create.
Currently we just create--
if you have 100 isolates that
want to run all in parallel,
currently we create
100 threads.
Maybe we'll try to limit that
at some point, so that they
start sharing threads
and so on.
But currently, this is not a
complexity that we are trying
to address, because there
are bigger fish to fry.
SETH LADD: Sure.
TODD TURNIDGE: We do reclaim
idle threads right now.
So if you reach some peak and
you go down, we'll reclaim
them if they're fallow
for awhile.
SETH LADD: Well, this is
probably an area that we'd
love feedback from our
external users.
How are they using isolates?
What kind of systems
are they building?
What kind of limits
do they run into?
And what are the use cases that
prompts these limits?
So I guess this is a question,
really, for everyone watching.
Do try out the isolates on
the virtual machine.
Try it with your systems,
your libraries.
Let us know how it works for
you, what kind of additional
control you might need.
And I'll take this opportunity
to remind everyone, this is
Dartisans Episode 5, where we're
meeting with the Dart VM
team today.
And you can follow along
at html5rocks.com/live.
And we have a Moderator
and a chat there.
So you can participate
there as well.
So I have a couple more
questions, and then I think
we'll dive into the Moderator
questions.
So what are the plans
for debugging?
I saw some debugging already
from the editor that goes into
Dartium, the web browser.
What's the team working
on right
now in terms of debugging?
IVAN POSVA: So in terms
of debugging--
Matthias isn't here, so I'll
try to answer for him.
In terms of debugging, the first
effort was to be able to
debug Dartium.
So you have an app in your web
browser, hook it up to the
Chrome Developer Console, set
break points, inspect the
stack, variables of the
stack, and so on.
That is mostly working.
I'm sure there are still some
grey areas in that stuff that
is not implemented properly.
But the feedback I
got from some of
developers was very positive.
And then, we switched
gears a bit.
Now it's being able to debug
standalone programs, be it
scripts, be it server
programs.
Generally, we talk about
Dartium and how
Dart is inside Chrome.
With Dart IO, you can build
pretty beefy servers.
We use some of it for our
internal Dart infrastructure
for testing and so on.
So you can build pretty
beefy programs.
So far Mads and his team have
been doing print, println,
print debugging.
So they want to have something
that is more like a real
developer experience
for those programs.
So that's what we've
been doing.
And there is a wide protocol
being defined.
It's JSON to some debugger
process.
You have the debugee.
And I know Matthias has been
working on it a basically
small Dart program that can
basically be used as a
debugger itself, like a
command line debugger.
Or you hook it up
with the other.
SIVA ANNAMALAI: Yeah.
That is kind of a test program
for testing the wide protocol.
IVAN POSVA: And I think if it
becomes useful, that test
program can actually mature into
something that you can
use like GDB, let's say.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
IVAN POSVA: command line.
SETH LADD: Right.
Debugger, yeah.
IVAN POSVA:
SETH LADD: But I think this is
a great clarification for
everyone watching, is that Dart
is-- the virtual machine
is not just targeted
to web browsers.
And as you were mentioning, we
have a suite of I/O libraries,
like files and directories, raw
sockets, web servers, that
all run from the command line,
essentially, as a server.
And our Hackathon attendees, for
instance, everyone was--
not everyone.
Many people were doing client-
and server-based apps.
And many people were asking
about the debugging.
And so it's cool to see that
that's on their radar.
But I love that about Dart.
You can have the same code on
the client and the server
running and some nice
code sharing.
And it's cool.
Same constructs in
both places.
Another big feature that
always comes up in
conversation that I get and
questions is reflection.
How will reflection
work in Dart?
And we hear rumblings of this
system called Mirrors.
And I think, Todd, are
you working on yours?
Can you talk a little
bit about--
TODD TURNIDGE: We get to
do a lot of fun work.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SETH LADD: So what
are mirrors?
Where is just simple
reflection?
TODD TURNIDGE: Well, one
of the people in
our team, Gilad Bracha--
he wrote an interesting
paper about mirrors.
It's just an approach to
reflection that tries to avoid
certain downfalls in
other systems.
Each object has an associated
object called a mirror.
And the mirror could
refer to a local
object or a remote object.
You don't have to have this
mirror to have it do all of
the reflective operations.
And he argues a lot for it in
the paper, in terms of he
stratifies which things you can
do at which level, and it
tends to make a cleaner
conceptual
break in the system.
And it also tends to be more
of the thing you could take
one mirror implementation and
substitute in a different one.
So this one might be
your local mirrors.
This one might be your
remote mirrors.
This one might be a different
kind of mirrors.
Instead of going on the
live program, it
reflects on a language--
IVAN POSVA: A core dump.
TODD TURNIDGE: Or a core dump
or something like that.
And so it's a lot like
dependency injection.
If you design it right, you
can inject a new library
implementation.
So in terms of implementation,
it's still
early days for that.
We're just beginning to
implement his proposal and
flush out the details of that.
IVAN POSVA: Yeah.
Also, some of the ideas he has
is that that you can have that
mirrors can have certain
capabilities.
Maybe you can only inspect,
not change a program, and
stuff like that.
He wants to be able to use
mirrors to build out
completely new isolates.
So you basically say, OK, give
me a new isolate mirror.
I want to load this library into
it, this library into it,
and this other library
into it.
And then I add this code.
And then it loads
another method.
Or maybe even pre-populate
it with some state.
And then call this
method on it.
So it's really like--
TODD TURNIDGE: It's like
a dynamic code
loading kind of thing.
IVAN POSVA: Legos for your
program, and then you say, OK,
now it's done--
run.
And mirrors are then strong
enough to kind of do the
reflection yourself, or
basically do more than just
reflection yourself.
Build up new objects
and so on.
SETH LADD: Are you aware of
any other systems that use
this concept of mirrors?
Or is Dart going to be one of
the first or the first that is
implementing this for real world
kind of applications?
IVAN POSVA: You worked on
[? Strunk, ?] right?
MALE SPEAKER 1: Yeah, I
worked a little bit.
I was mostly working on
some other parts.
TODD TURNIDGE: Did he do it
with this other language?
IVAN POSVA: Yes, I think.
Newspeak has it.
So it's been around
for a while.
These ideas.
They've not been
used too much.
But on the other hand, for
example, if you used V8, and
you used the debugging V8, all
of the debugging API behind
the scenes is implemented
with these mirrors.
So you can't really tell,
but that's what it uses
underneath.
SETH LADD: This is a hot
feature request.
So it's cool to hear that we
have a really solid plan.
We've seen this implemented in
other languages, and it's
coming for Dart.
And I think it will enable a
lot of great lower-level
libraries that people will
build on top of.
Things like JSON parsing could
really love the mirrors as you
reconstruct an object based
on some text streams.
So yeah, that's great.
Before we dive into questions,
I have another question on
language design impacting
VM design.
One of the more novel features
of Dart is its optional
static-type annotations.
Now, I'm just curious how that
might have impacted, at all,
if at all, the VM design.
Did you have to go to a new
place in VM design because of
these optional static types?
Or is the way they designed them
for them to be decoupled
and it really didn't impact?
What was the intersection
there?
MALE SPEAKER 1: So optional
typing is known from
JavaScript and from
[INAUDIBLE].
Now, in addition to that, we
need to do this optional
static run-time checking.
So those checks need to be
eliminated, need to be
efficient, and so on, so on.
We have a lot of novel ideas how
to do this correctly and
efficiently.
We are not yet there, so the
run-time checks, they're a
little bit too slow
for our taste.
We are working on making the
check mode as fast as we can
and putting optimization
to get it done.
So making these optional
run-time checks very quick is
a challenge.
We have found that a lot of--
that the idea of optional
typing and these--
it's kind of novel to
many people who are
accustomed to it.
If you started typing, and I
think there's a lot of people
who have to get used to that.
How they can use that
efficiently in their systems
is a challenge, but I
think it's worth it.
IVAN POSVA: I think really you
can tell some of the team
members skip the V8 step.
In JavaScript, you have no
types, you have no static
types, and you always have to
figure it out at run-time.
For some, that came from
statically typed languages.
It was hard to let go of,
but it's right here.
It has this type.
While this is only--
it is not guaranteed
to be correct.
So it is otherwise-- so unless
they're in check mode, you
can't rely on that.
From the VM's perspective,
even though a type was
specified, we read
it as a bar.
We don't know anything about
it until we get the type
feedback on it.
SETH LADD: Right.
And that's where that check
mode, as you were talking
about, comes into play.
For those who don't know, Dart
can run in really two
different modes.
One mode we call production mode
where all these optional
static type annotations
are effectively--
or where you were saying,
you just see a bar.
But then you flip a flag and you
get check mode where the
VM and the other run times
begin to respect these
optional static type annotations
can do some
dynamic type assertions.
IVAN POSVA: Yeah.
It's developer mode,
more like it.
So you really-- you're
expecting this
type T here, right?
And you make sure that the
variable being assigned has
that or the value being assigned
to this variable has
the appropriate time.
MALE SPEAKER 1: It's important
to know also that when you add
types to Dart, it doesn't
improve your performance.
So you're not using the
type information to
generate better code.
And we feel we don't need it.
We think with all the obstacles
to the technology
that we have to this position,
we don't need that to generate
code of high performance.
SETH LADD: Great.
SIVA ANNAMALAI: It's more for
employing program productivity
in terms of making the code more
legible and how we are
structuring it and
things like that.
Everybody knows JavaScript is
probably hard to read and
understand.
But we're trying.
That's one of the prime
goals, was that.
IVAN POSVA: And then you can add
the static type warnings
on top of it during
the run time.
We don't look at it, but ahead
of time, you already got
static type warnings
from the editor.
You're assigning something
that doesn't match here.
Is this really all you want?
Occasionally, you know better.
SETH LADD: And for those that do
use the editor, you get the
static type warnings.
And if you don't use the editor,
there's a standalone
program that we're continuing
to improve which can run
through your code and give you
these static warnings so you
can integrate into your tool
chain as you see fit.
So it's really, really nice.
One other feature I remembered
of the Dart
virtual machine is snapshots.
Has anyone been working
on snapshots lately?
SIVA ANNAMALAI: Yeah.
We did an initial round of
snapshotting the whole code
libraries and in the case of
Dartium, the whole DOM and
[INAUDIBLE] libraries,
which are kind of now
in-built into the VM.
So any time an isolate is
started, it doesn't re-read
all these code libraries.
It just starts off from
the snapshot.
So what the advantage of that is
you don't have to tokenize
the whole thing again.
So you get that all in priority,
and it kind of
speeds up the starting
process.
Apart from that, we also have
something called application
snapshots, which Dartium has
been using it, in that when
you first load an application,
it creates a snapshot of that
application, stores it off
in the builder cache.
And then subsequent reload of
the page full start from the
builder cache and runs it, which
again, the advantage is
it skips over all the tokenizing
and the whole
parsing concept.
SETH LADD: Does the snapshot
system-- this is might be a
Dartium question, but
how does it know
to expire that snapshot?
Does it look at some of the
headers coming in from the
source file?
SIVA ANNAMALAI: Yeah.
It's the same standard
[INAUDIBLE]
cache expiry policy that they
have in the regular browser.
It's the same thing you apply
to this, too, if it expires.
IVAN POSVA: They just
stick the binary
blob into the cache.
Instead of the resource,
they load it.
Or next to the resource,
Maybe we need to take
a step back.
What is inside a snapshot?
So as we said, on your
earlier question, how
does it even get going?
What do we need to do
to start up a VM?
Well, we parse the program.
We build up its internal data
structures so that we don't
have to re-parse the individual
characters.
We have this, what we
call a token stream.
So all of that structure
lives in the snapshot.
So when you reload the snapshot,
basically, the whole
structure of the--
these classes are
this library.
These methods and fields are
associated with these classes.
All of that is basically
read in from a
serialized object stream.
These objects are recreated
again immediately without any
real parsing going on.
So that's basically where
the snapshot starts.
That's why Siva can say, well,
you have a snapshot.
You just reload it.
Boom, here's your VM.
SIVA ANNAMALAI: So the way to
look at it is to say it's a
snapshot of the image of the
heap that was there after we
did the initial parsing and
built up all the initial data
structures and so on.
So that heap has been dumped
into this, again, serialized
into this buffer.
And then we deserialize it the
next time we load it so that
the heap just comes out without
having done any of the
initial parsing and all that.
IVAN POSVA: I don't know.
Some of the viewers
might have seen--
when they looked in the V8
implementation details, there
is a snapshot there as well,
because V8 has--
some areas of the JavaScript
libraries are written in
JavaScript itself for V8.
So what V8 does, basically it
snapshots that part of the
core libraries.
The problem for JavaScript
versus Dart is that you build
up your program structure beyond
what is really known to
the VM itself.
It needs to execute code.
And to properly be able to
snapshot things, it's really
hard to figure out once you
start executing code.
With the Dart language, you have
this structure is in the
class, not as executing
programs.
It's in the source code.
So that's why we can snapshot
bigger things, even
applications.
SETH LADD: I think some of the
initial research the Seattle
team did was 10 times
better start-up
performance due to snapshots.
And so I'm really looking
forward to that.
So let's go ahead and take some
of our viewer questions
from the Moderator.
If you're just joining us,
html5rocks.com/live has a link
to this Moderator.
You can vote up and down
questions or ask your own.
We'll start right at the top.
Our buddy Ladislav, who is
prolific on the general
discussion mailing list.
So thanks for all
your help there.
TODD TURNIDGE: We should
say hi Ladislav.
I see a lot of his emails.
IVAN POSVA: same with us.
SETH LADD: He asks, "If I
understand correctly, isolates
are meant to be very lightweight
in Dart.
Yet the VM trashes my OS badly
if I create like 100 of them."
TODD TURNIDGE: Yeah, he has a
bug open for this, I think.
SETH LADD: OK. "What are the
intricacies in this, and how
do you plan to tackle them?" So
I know we talked about it a
little bit, but if there's a
bug, have we thought about
anything more?
TODD TURNIDGE: Well, I need to
re-review the bug now that we
have the thread pools.
I think the bug was
file before that.
And then there's just--
we consume a certain amount
of resources per isolate.
And we need to just start
turning the screws on that.
And then there's even some
objects that we could share
across all isolates.
Ivan did some work recently with
something called class
indexes that are where an object
doesn't need to refer
to its class for its own heap.
It can refer to just the general
notion of I am a
string and what a string
is in isolate.
One might be a little different
than this one, but
we can actually share
the data.
And so we could start to
actually share a lot more
between isolates.
I don't know if that'll
help with-- it
will help with scaling.
IVAN POSVA: Oh, it will
help definitely on
a per isolate overhead.
TODD TURNIDGE: Per isolate
overhead is sort of what's
trashing your OS problem
over there.
IVAN POSVA: And if it's not the
threads anymore, then it's
the per-isolate overhead
is much higher
than we want it to.
We have a grand plan
to get there.
And it's essentially the three
of us that need to get some of
these ideas that we hashed
out, implemented.
SIVA ANNAMALAI: And also, our
heap policy right now is not
that great, so we tend to just
keep growing the heap.
And so the isolate
takes more--
the fill time starts
to increase.
And I think Ivan has a plan
on trying to do a more
progressive growth of the heap,
so it should reduce that
footprint also.
SETH LADD: Cool.
Well, it's great to hear so much
interest and attention
from the outside world
and then from the VM
engineers as well.
So Adam, who is another one of
our early adopters up in San
Francisco actually asks--
oop, I just lost it.
"Can you explain what object
tagging means in the VM
world?" Looks like he's someone
who likes to dive into
the source code a little bit.
Is there a way to--
IVAN POSVA: It's unclear what
the-- well, I think I know
what he asks.
TODD TURNIDGE: Is he asking
about small integers?
IVAN POSVA: think that's
what it is.
SIVA ANNAMALAI: Actually, can
we-- if he is live, can he ask
us what exactly he meant
by object tagging?
I'm a little confused on what
he meant by object tagging.
SETH LADD: We'll follow up.
I know he's on another
event today.
So Adam, we'll follow
up with you offline.
Ask again on the mailing list.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
IVAN POSVA: OK.
If I heard this question
without any--
I thought maybe we can get a
little bit more info of what
he wanted to know.
In the VM, we--
like a lot of the language
virtual machines that don't
have static types for integers
and other basic types,
integers are really, really
frequently used.
So what we do is we have
pointers that we just add a
little bit as one.
That means those are tagged.
These are real pointers.
And then integers themselves,
all integers
have the low-bit zero.
They're basically shifted by,
excuse me, by one bit to the
left so we have--
instead of 32-bit integers on
the 32-bit machine, we have
31-bit integers that we
can very efficiently
represent in the VM.
And so the low bit really tells
us, when we look at what
is an object reference, the low
bit tells us, OK, this is
what we call a small integer,
a 31-bit integer on a x86 or
an ARM versus a real object
pointer that we have to--
where we can get at
its class and its
fields a different way.
If you tried to call integer
methods on that, on one of
these smize or small integers,
we can't load the class out of
the object because
it's not there.
We have to find the class
somewhere else.
That's where the class index
and so on helps us swap
because we can then
just load it.
TODD TURNIDGE: And it means
that we can compile pretty
efficient code for integers.
MALE SPEAKER 1: And it's also
true, for example, sometimes
you have two operations between
those, but it won't be
the integer that's-- it'll just
be an integer which is
larger than 31-bit.
It creates an object.
It gets stacked, and then
present that new integer and
get [INAUDIBLE] to it.
IVAN POSVA: Yeah.
To the user, it's completely
transparent.
MALE SPEAKER 1: For us,
it makes it easy to--
especially for the optimizing
compiler, you just basically--
for a lot of operations, you
can just-- during normal
integer operations, you
check whether the low
bits have been set.
And then you're back
off to the races.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Your performance
provides and
incredible help and is very
simple to implement.
The next step for doubles,
you cannot do that.
And all the double operations
need to go via objects in the
un-optimization.
We're working very hard on
making doubles, real doubles,
machine double, and to bring
the performance up.
IVAN POSVA: Yeah.
And then on a 64-bit VM, a lot
of people, I think, are
starting to use that as well.
On a 64-bit VM, while it's 63
bit of small integers, I think
that is a--
TODD TURNIDGE: Which is
a lot of small int.
IVAN POSVA: Yeah, that
is a pretty large
value for a small integer.
And then, yeah, we have a couple
behind the scenes.
We have this whole integer
hierarchy.
From a small integer, you flow
over to a medium integer,
which is really a
64-bit value.
It's heap-allocated, but then
we just use the regular
machine instructions
to operate on that.
Then, you flow over to
the big end, which
is arbitrarily sized.
SETH LADD: And we should
probably talk about the
language semantics are that
integers are arbitrarily--
IVAN POSVA: Sized.
SETH LADD: --sized or--
yeah.
Great.
Well, OK, we've got about
10 minutes left.
Songhun Kim, who leads the
Korea Darlang User Group,
asks, "Are we sharing any
benchmarks between the Dart VM
and V8?" And what I think he's
really asking is how are we
kind of measuring ourselves?
MALE SPEAKER 1: We have
benchmarks written in
JavaScript and in Dart,
and none of them--
the JavaScript benchmarks we
run on the best JavaScript
engine available now, which is
V8 and compare it to dart2dart
and track this on
a daily basis.
And we are seeing improvement.
And we will see more and more
improvement until we can
develop faster than V8.
IVAN POSVA: Currently, I don't
think we're there yet.
SETH LADD: Still very early,
but it's great to hear that
we're tracking this stuff.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Absolutely.
SETH LADD: Another question I
believe probably came in from
the comments or the chat stream
was, "What types of
things are being put into the
Dart VM to allow developers to
control/be notified
about GC events?
This is a large problem at
high-performance JavaScript
applications where apps can't
control when a GC flush
occurs." Any thoughts about--
I think this is really asking
about two things.
One, he's asking, can I be
notified when GC occurs?
And two, can I control when
a GC might occur?
As VM engineers, I'm sure you've
seen systems built one
way or the other.
What are your thoughts there?
SIVA ANNAMALAI: In terms of
notification, the Dart API, if
I remember right, the Dartium
did request it, and delivered
a notification that we call
back from the Dart API, I
think, is--
TODD TURNIDGE: Yeah, at the
embedder level, you can
certainly--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SIVA ANNAMALAI: As an embedder,
you can actually
register yourself.
TODD TURNIDGE: You can control
all call-backs, upload
call-backs and weak reference
sets and the whole thing.
SIVA ANNAMALAI: But in terms of
controlling it, I have some
strong views on that.
Maybe others don't share it, but
I've generally felt that
trying to control when a GC
happens is not quite a good
approach, because the garbage
collector does have heuristics
built into it to control
these things.
And you know that it has been--
at least my experience
with these things have been that
the nicely implemented
garbage collector in the VM
does a pretty good job of
knowing when garbage
collection should
happen and does it.
IVAN POSVA: So when you look
at the other languages that
allow exposure of the GC event
and trigger GC here, good VM's
implementing these languages
generally ignore these calls,
because it's been-- often in
our experience, it's been
often at the wrong time.
TODD TURNIDGE: And also, we've
got a different environment,
because we have per-isolate
heaps.
IVAN POSVA:
TODD TURNIDGE: So in other
systems, you might have a
stop-the-world GC, where it
actually affects all threads.
Here, there's no need for any
other isolate to stop just
because one isolate
needs the GC.
Also, you should also expect
that that heap will be sort of
proportional to the size of
work that isolate's doing.
That isolate's heap might be a
lot easier to collect than the
whole thing.
So in terms of global hiccups,
you should expect fewer and
where we hope they'd
be smaller.
But I'm not a GC guy.
IVAN POSVA: Currently, there's
a lot of work that I and Carl
implemented.
Maybe with help from [INAUDIBLE]
or somebody else.
And in the GC, as Siva mentioned
already, that growth
policy is completely
not implemented.
So we just keep growing old
space until you reach its max.
And then even though we know
that maybe there's not enough
live to warrant the growth of
that into the next size, that
will be more efficient to
collect now, stuff like that.
SETH LADD: Well, I'm wondering
also if the tooling systems
can also help developers with
large memory, high-performance
applications as well?
I know that developer tools
in Chrome give you some
visibility into what's
going on.
So the feeling here is not being
able to manually trigger
is probably the right thing.
But I think we could do things
at the tooling level to help
people get visibility.
IVAN POSVA: I think Carl has a
prototype where he kind of
gives you a heap dump.
What is live now?
And where is it being
held from?
And you should be able to
graphically inspect that here
is this object.
Why does it live?
Who points to it?
And so on.
How far he is along with
that, I don't know.
SETH LADD: Well, I've got
a couple more questions.
Ladislav asks, again, "As far as
I know, the coming debugger
communicates with the VM via
adjacent-based protocol,"
which I think we covered
earlier.
"My wild guess is that this must
bring some overhead, and
that some binary format
like Protobufs
might be more efficient.
Is that the case or am I wrong?"
is what he asks.
IVAN POSVA: It's probably JSON
or Protobufs or some binary
format would be more compact.
It might be easier to parse
on the other end.
I don't think it's huge.
And it's-- you're dealing
with a human.
So the latency--
TODD TURNIDGE: We don't
generally have debugger
benchmarks that we
pay attention to.
I guess probably people
who do GDB do.
But generally, if you hit Next
and then, in a reasonable
amount of time, you see the
Next statement come up.
SIVA ANNAMALAI: But usually
it's not the wide protocol
that dominates a Next.
And there's a lot more things
going on behind the scenes for
a implementation of Next.
And the tradeoff here, that,
of course, JSON is a pretty
popular format that a lot of
other tools might already be
aware of using it.
So the tradeoff is it's pretty
good in that aspect.
So we get a protocol that a
lot of other people might
already understand
as opposed to a
proprietary binary format.
IVAN POSVA: The human-readable
is always nice for debugging
in these areas.
SETH LADD: I think I agree.
IVAN POSVA: I mean, debugging
the debugger protocol itself.
That gets us probably there more
quickly than if we had to
count bits on the wire when
we're figuring out, why
doesn't this work?
SETH LADD: And just like most
things that we're working on
now, this is all early days.
And so who knows what the
future will bring.
But I agree.
Less moving parts, less unique
capabilities, more
human-readable at this stage,
probably better.
OK.
Great.
Well, last question.
Something a little
bit different.
"What types of things would
game developers need to be
aware of at the VM level to
write high-performance code?"
And to elaborate more, we have
the question asker here on the
other side of the camera,
Colt, who is a very
experienced game developer.
And I know he's been working a
lot building web-based games.
So is there something that
you are particularly--
like a angle on that question?
COLT MCANLIS: Just the
larger deep-dive.
When game developers are writing
HTML5 code, they have
to have the mental model of how
JavaScript is working and
then the secondary model of what
that actually turns into
when you have sat
on the fence.
And I didn't know if there was
anything you guys have done
already with performance or
profiling that you may want to
think about, or be aware of,
or at least notify the
community of that are things
that they should start
thinking about when trying to
write games that run at 60
Hertz with full graphics, and
sound running, and networking,
and everything.
IVAN POSVA: OK.
So I think I would start
off with, don't
mix ints and doubles.
Excuse me.
In JavaScript, you don't
necessarily have that problem,
because it's just kind
of a big mishmash
in the number hierarchy.
For us, it's really helpful if
you say, I'm going to use this
as a double.
Define your constants as 1.0
instead of 1, stuff like that.
That helps dramatically.
Some of the type feedback I
think will make this easier to
deal with in the optimizing
compiler.
SETH LADD: What about games
with a lot of matrix math?
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah.
Lots of linear optimization
and range reversal.
MALE SPEAKER 1: I think it's
important not to deduct
certain performance
characteristics from where we
are now, because where
we are going is
going to be quite different.
If you figure out, oh, this,
if I do it that way, it's
going to be much faster
than the other way.
It doesn't mean it's going
to stay that way.
So we are trying to improve.
We are focused on improving the
normal code, which means,
bright clean code,
simple code.
Don't go, oh, I have to code
this and this and that.
And then I'm going to
get faster because I
made it right now.
That's even not going
to be the future.
Simple code, clean code
should work very good.
IVAN POSVA: Yeah.
And if it doesn't, file a bug.
The other thing is, we already
have the whole native arrays
for floats, and then
they're typed.
So you can really say,
I want the float
32 or float 64 arrays.
You can have them external if
you want to, so that they're
shared with a graphics card
and so on from a web
developer's perspective.
Unfortunately, I think they're
not exactly hooked into
Dartium yet.
So I think that is
the next step.
So in the VM, they're
supported.
But if you ask for a type array
from Dartium, you get a
different copy.
MALE SPEAKER 1: And I hope in
the future, you'll be able
soon to get a bit more precise
set of documentation for the
performance, but now it's
way too early for that.
SETH LADD: I think we have Box2D
wired into some of our
performance metrics.
So that's something used by a
lot of web developers, and
that's good.
I think it's-- as long as it's
on that radar, that's great.
Well, I think that's all
the time we have today.
So I want to thank everyone for
watching and certainly all
your questions.
And then, of course, our
engineers from the Dart VM
team, thank you very much
for spending your
time with us today.
This is all going to be recorded
and posted to our
YouTube channel, so you
can catch up there.
And please do follow Google
Chrome Developers and
Dart-structured web apps in
Google+ for more Hangouts like
this, and where we post news
and announcements, and
interact with the community
every day.
So thanks everyone for their
time, and we'll see you next
time on Dartisans.